[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi
28 octobre bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 hebdo une émission pour
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine
voici les titres nouvelle vie pour le
quartier du rotois raillencourt les
aménagements ont démarré il y a déjà dix
ans logement groupe scolaire ou espaces
verts doivent permettent de créer une
nouvelle dynamique la fin des travaux
est prévue pour 2018 jean-marie têtards
député de la 9e circonscription des
yvelines et maire de houdan est notre
invité fil rouge pour cette émission
nous parlerons avec lui des chiffres du
chômage en baisse ce mois-ci alors que
son territoire connaît le taux de
chômage le plus faible de france dans le
reste de l'actualité nous reviendrons
sur la colère des policiers qui se sont
rassemblés devant le palais de justice
de versailles ou le soutien scolaire qui
se développe dans l'agglomération à
travers notamment internet je vous
disais dans les titres l'aménagement du
quartier dur ou poire à guyancourt se
poursuit le maire de la ville françois
de ligné et les équipes d'eiffage en
charge de l'aménagement du quartier sont
revenus ce jeudi lors d'une présentation
sur la construction des nouveaux
équipements et la diversité des
infrastructures le reportage de nicolas
d'andré
résidences de tourisme 200 logements
nouveaux locaux pour le groupe scolaire
jean lurçat c'est le visage actuel du
quartier du pont du rotois à guyancourt
depuis 2006 l'entreprise eiffage travail
sur l'aménagement de ce terrain en
développant différentes infrastructures
il fallait que le projet soit
adapté aux besoins de la ville de
guyancourt et c'est vrai que nous
n'avons pas cherché à valoriser à
outrance ce foncier par créer des
escalopes de logements
sur ce site met effectivement en
respectant les choix la municipalité
donc d'arriver à conserver notamment de
l'activité de l'activité sera créé avec
une clinique de rééducation de 200 lits
sa livraison est prévue pour la fin de
l'année 2016 avec à la clé environ 150
emplois pour la ville ce qui était très
important
c'était d'arriver à faire comprendre
qu'on avait une vision qu'on voulait
déséquilibre et après évidemment il a
fallu créer avec eiffage les conditions
ça s'est fait par des échanges de
terrains et ça s'est fait surtout dans
le respect des exigences de la ville en
terme d'aménagement cet été deux permis
de construire ont été déposés pour la
création d'une résidence
intergénérationnelle
la réalisation d'un espace commun au
sein de cette résidence et surtout donc
la venue d'un opérateur d'une
association qui s'appelle réciprocité
qui permet effectivement de fédérer
autour même donc d'un animateur au
départ l'ensemble des habitants de cet
nouvel espace pour arriver à trouver les
activités commun de retrouver du lien
social la livraison de ce projet devrait
intervenir courant 2018 pour conclure
plus de dix ans de réaménagement sur le
quartier du pont du rotois re à
guyancourt
[Musique]
et pour évoquer à présent dans
l'actualité de la semaine jean-marie
tétard député-maire des yvelines nous a
rejoint sur le plateau bonsoir soit on
va débuter avec vous à propos des
chiffres du chômage fortement en baisse
ce mois-ci au mois de septembre plutôt
-2 2 % sur le département des yvelines -
1,9 pour cent sur l'ensemble de la
france des chiffres et des baies ce que
l'on avait pas vu depuis et des mois
voire des années est ce qu'on peut dire
que françois hollande et son
gouvernement concrètement c'est en train
de gagner la bataille du chômage à
quelques mois des élections
présidentielles je vous dirai ça aussi
malheureusement le dicton qui dit qu'une
hirondelle ne fait pas le printemps
donc pour l'instant on sait déjà qu'on a
un certain nombre de dérèglements
saisonniers avec françois hollande noël
était aux pratiques des états annonce de
nouveaux financements à payer plus tard
il en a une bonne nouvelle sur le
chômage me réjouis pour ceux qui peuvent
profiter de nouveaux emplois même si je
pense qu'il ya aussi à analyser les
statistiques de classement on a essayé
différentes catégories de jadis et ceux
qui ne travaillent pas à baisser on va
prendre ça comme une bonne nouvelle à
confirmer mais d'autres le dr g un slot
gros moi qui me qui m'interrogent dans
la vie c'est de dire que souvent doit
laisser en sortant les choses comme
elles étaient en entrant et c'est pas
parce qu'il y aurait une petite
inversion de la courbe que nous
pourrions de être satisfaits de nos
satisfecit à françois hollande parce que
paul 600000 ou sept cent mille chômeurs
de plus depuis des tarifs est d'ailleurs
un sondage aux hawks a paru ce vendredi
28 octobre indique que huit français sur
dix ne croit pas à la version du chômage
ça vous étonne de voir que alors que ces
chiffres sont impressionnantes même mois
1,9 pour cent sur en moi de ne pas
croire à un début d'inversion de chemin
oui mais je veux voir que mon a classé
les chômeurs dans l'édition de catégorie
et puis euh 9,6 succédera à 6 mois ou
sept mois de l'élection à venir c'est
l'un après ce non non c'est pas ça c'est
que moi je considère qu'il ya 700 milles
encore chômeurs depuis 2012 c'est cela
qui m'intéresse donc on ne peut pas se
réjouir tout de suite mais
éventuellement c'est un bon signe ces
dames aussi mais c'est avant sydney a
confirmé alors jean marie d'état vous
êtes sur ce plateau parce qu
vous êtes aussi le député-maire du
territoire qui a le taux de chômage le
plus faible de france alors on parle du
pays où d'année mais j'ai bien compris
que c'était pas le terme exact mais en
tout cas la ville de houdan en fait
partie sur ce territoire la 88 % de
personnes sont sans emploi c'est le taux
de chômage de plus france est ce que
c'est le plus bas de france est ce que
cette réputation est exagéré selon vous
à l'oral est elle et elle est méritée
bon alors c'est forcément mérité puisque
c'est une statistique exacte sur les
mêmes bases et lille c'est sur un
quelque chose qui s'appelle une zone
d'emploi qui comprend environ va que
nous vivons de houdan jusqu'à jusqu'à
jouars-pontchartrain en prenant mes
rêves en passant donc c'est une
statistique sur un territoire bien
défini sur lequel les cons sont comparés
taux de chômage d'année en année
ça fait plusieurs années que ce bassin
d'emploi a le meilleur taux de chômage
de france alors là dedans il ya mauvaise
élève saoudien qui a taux de chômage
plus importants alors qu'une plus
importante qui reste raisonnable oui oui
mais pour cent oui mais faut qu'on
s'explique que là dessus alors des
caisses quand on m'interroge sow est ce
qu'il ya un miracle n'a pas de miracle
et une situation favorable la situation
d'un droit peut s'expliquer comment on
est dans un axe le long de la rn 12 et
doit féret
qui va montparnasse donc cette zone
d'emploi tac je viens de décrire à une
possibilité d'accès facile à des emplois
sur l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines sur paris sur la région par la
diète ça c'est un premier mois fait
preuve d'humilité finalement vous dit
que c'est pas les décisions politiques
et joseph je vous donne des facteurs
favorables dans blais ensuite il ya
dynamisme cette région et
particulièrement du pnue d'année je
crois que depuis un certain nombre
d'années nous avons une stratégie qui
conduit aujourd'hui de territoire de
houtan le territoire communal de houdan
à avoir un taux d'emploi de 1,7 je crois
le plus haut des hymnes à vélizy ah
qu'est ce que ça veut dire un taux
d'emploi de 1,7 concrètement pour ceux
qui c'est très simple ça veut dire que
sur le territoire géographique de
houdain nous avons 1,7 emploi pour un
actif du territoire natal d'emploi qu'un
actif de d'actifs du talent toit se dire
que nous sommes excédentaires et que
donc des personnes qui n'habitent pas
aux dents peuvent effectivement venir
travailler autant donc deux choses une
situation favorable je vous l'expliquais
d'accès au territoire du bassin d'emploi
important que la région parisienne
deuxièmement de l'emploi local pour que
petit à petit on ne puisse plus être
simplement une situation domicile
travail donc création d'emplois sur
place l'exemple de woods était donc cet
emploi subsistent dans le temps il faut
en fait le faire reposer sur trois
piliers un pilier qui est l'emploi
public celui là il se délocalise pas
l'hôpital local les maisons de retraite
les maisons de deux d'adaptation du
handicap c'est à ce sont des emplois qui
se délocalise pas il faut un emploi
industriel sont nos zones d'activités
que depuis vingt ans nous avons
développé en ayant un objectif ne pas
consommer trop de terres agricoles ça
c'est difficile ce nom c'est important
ça veut dire qu'il faut se donner un
objectif d'emploi à l'hectare on sait
qu'on n'aura pas les danses et des
emplois de la défense nous interdira de
construire très haut mais par contre
nous sommes donné un objectif d'emploi
ou dans et dans le pays où dan est
d'environ 40 35 à 40 emplois à l'hectare
ce qui veut dire que ne vont pas des
magasins des industries de la logistique
avec des grands espaces vides en
concrètement vous favorisez les pme et
terje les tpe et les gars merci au co
alors ça c'est le troisième pilier les
commerces locaux c'est à dire que nous
défendons effectivement un centre ville
avec des commerces de proximité jeu on
compta ou dans 120 tout ça grimpe au
pont pour la ville ou dans la voix la
comité colloque de nom pour la ville de
mollesse deux mois seulement et et cela
c'est une bagarre de tous les jours donc
en fait ces emplois aussi sont aussi
créateur saisir le centre-ville de ou
dans le centre commercial centre ville
d'oujda est aussi créateur d'emplois et
des zones commerciales qui leur tour
expliquez-nous comment au maintien 120
commerces locaux dans une ville comme
houdan alors quand on sait que c'est une
problématique importante aujourd'hui en
france et même même ici à saint quentin
et des communes qui s'inquiète de voir
leurs commerces fermés comment quel est
votre formule magique il n'y a pas de
fond les commerces le valence et je
crois qu'il faut une volonté un
partenariat et une volonté il faut
protéger les commerces locaux ça prend
différentes dimensions savané qui ont de
la contrainte la contrainte partir de
commerce de détail à houdan ne peut pas
se transformer en logements où environ
nourrir de détail ne peuvent pas être
plus par une banque c'est dans notre
pêche c'est aussi éviter de grandes
zones commerciales autour il faut
effectivement une complémentarité entre
les commerces du centre ville et des
commerces de type zone commerciale mais
en gros ou non agréé n'a pas du gain qui
peut parfois être alléchant d'avoir une
grosse zone commerciale ça peut ça fait
aussi rentrer de l'argent tant les
risques d'une mairie d'une communauté
commune il faut avoir la fiscalité oble
c'est à dire qu'effectivement il faut
plus que le levier là aussi du coup la
fiscalité oui des fiscalités pour
attirer des industriels par exemple
c'est une fiscalité ou faible nous
savons encore à des taux à un chiffre et
quand ils sont à deux chiffres sont
plutôt inférieure à 12 ans tôt ils ont
tous avoir la moitié des taux que l'on
peut trouver rien sont des ventes de
terrains possédé par la communauté de
communes je crois que pour avoir une
vraie politique faut posséder états qui
sont pas des prix de type 45 euros à 50
euros le mètre carré mais c'est aussi
pour le commerce évitez les grandes
zones commerciales ce que nous faisons
c'est aussi finalement comme je le dis
protéger les mutations et puis ça sera
aussi de l'animation skis alors moi je
voulais savoir ce qui se passe chez vous
toutes ces mesures vous mettez en place
que vous portez au sein de votre
communauté des communes et de votre de
votre ville est ce que selon vous on
peut le copier coller sur toutes les
agglomérations partout en france ou
alors à chaque territoire ces
problématiques et ses solutions à chaque
territoire ces problématiques et
solutions mais il aurait fallu que les
problématiques les solutions soit
dialysé plutôt quelquefois parce que
dans certaines situations de ville il
est trop tard il sera trop tard je
milite aussi pour qu'il n'y ait pas une
surenchère des zones commerciales dans
quelques années je crois que nous
trouverons des friches commerciales que
nous avons trouvé des friches
industrielles puisque quoi qu'on peut
inventer dans les villes de homs et aux
dents demain peut-être qu'il faut qu'il
y ait un drive du commerce de uno c'est
à dire un live et du commerce dans ce
cas ci ça veut dire qu'un endroit où les
gens viendraient chercher leurs courses
où tous les cas parce que les clients
auraient commandé par internet dans les
temps et dans l'est dans les boutiques
et tous les boutiques aurait regroupé
leurs leur accord ça veut dire qu'il
faut être imaginatif aussi et qui pour
cela il faut un bon partenaire une
association de commerçants donc c'est
aussi un des éléments un mot maintenant
rapidement pour terminer ce volet-là
économique et la croissance au troisième
trimestre en france plus 0,2 pour cent
la pluie aujourd'hui ce matin c'est peu
évidemment le gouvernement reconnaît
lui-même qu'il ne va probablement pas
tenir son objectif de 1,5 pour cent de
croissance
ça fait des années que la croissance
patine en france même sous la présidence
de nicolas sarkozy est-ce que c'est pas
finalement faut arrêter de rêver ce que
c'est pendant leurs deux d'imaginer une
croissance à nouveau en france de 3 ou
4% et qu'il faut s'habituer à une
croissance aussi molle sur les
politiques aujourd'hui que ce soit
notamment dans cette course à la
présidentielle il toujours moi je vais
aller chercher la croissance mais est-ce
que c'est pas un leurre aujourd'hui
d'aller chercher la croissance moi je
vois ma van bon je pense d'abord pour
finir sur le chômage qu'on peut pas se
réjouir effectivement que on attire des
entreprises à houdan parce que
finalement j'aimerais bien plus tôt
qu'on est plein d'entreprises qui se
créent dans toute la france donc
l'opportunité d'un territoire le fait
d'arriver en prendra d'autres
territoires c'est pas un but en soi tant
mieux pour mon territoire mais ce n'est
pas un but en soi sur la croissance je
crois qu'effectivement faut plus rêver
on aura des croissances différentes les
valeurs les organiser une croissance qui
une croissance qui se produit plus
d'emploi et notamment je reviens au taux
d'emploi il faut développer dans les
territoires des emplois peu qualifiés on
ne peut pas avoir de bons taux d'emploi
avec uniquement des start up et des
classes tard il faut avoir aussi des
emplois pour des non qualifiés lorsque à
dans le territoire soudanais nous avons
un abattoir avec 120 personnes peu
qualifiées
quand dans les services de type hôpitaux
il y à des agents hospitaliers qui font
les toilettes etc c'est un une nécessité
pour qu'il y ait un taux d'emploi qu'ils
soient bons donc il va falloir avoir une
croissance on a imaginé plus raisonnable
plus productive d'emploi et surtout en
utilisant mieux l'argent cette
croissance alors l'actualité cette
semaine a été marquée également par la
colère était policier qui continuent de
manifester dans certaines villes de
france mardi des rassemblements étaient
organisés devant les palais de justice
était le cas notamment à versailles je
vous propose d'écouter à ce propos le
représentant départemental du syndicat
unsa le rassemblement d'aujourd'hui
c'est pour que il une conscience qu'ils
soient prises au niveau du pouvoir
judiciaire nous demandons une
application plus ferme des lois et des
peines qui qu'encourent les individus
qui seraient auteurs de violences à
l'encontre des personnes dépositaires de
l'autorité publique comme les policiers
quand des peines sont prononcés à
l'encontre d'auteurs de violences qu'ont
les policiers nous estimons que les
peines sont trop faibles pour que ce
soit significatif et empêcher les
récidives il faut que ce soit des peines
qu'ils puissent être dissuasive alors la
colère des policiers ça fait maintenant
plusieurs semaines qu'à s'exprimer après
l'agression dans l'essonne de quatre
agents municipaux au cocktail molotov
quel regard vous portez sur cette colère
qui s'exprime
plutôt durement d'ailleurs avec des
propos assez durs envers la justice
l'état le sentiment d'abandon est ce que
vous partagez ce point de vue oui oui et
je constate d'abord qu'il faut quand
même pour qu'une corporation comme les
policiers
puissent quitter son droit de réserve
auquel elle est tenue il faut quand même
des éléments très grave il faut à la
fois une accumulation de frustrations et
et de sentiment de ne pas être bien
considéré est quelque chose qu ib qui
l'étincelle qui met le feu aux poudres
elle est à celle c'était viry-châtillon
quand vous parlez d'accumulation ça veut
dire que ça remonte avant 2011 sur mais
bien sûr ça remonte à très longtemps
c'est à la fois du manque de matériel
extra à toutes les époques sur les lieux
des plans d'équipement de matériel ils
ont toujours été en retard sur l'heure
sur le besoin donc on ne fait que
rattraper et puis ces locaux j'ai vu
combien de temps il a fallu pour qu'il y
ait un commissariat de police flambant
neuf aux mureaux il a fallu que mon
prédécesseur henri cuq sang occulte le
maire des mureaux sont occupés pour
qu'enfin il ya un an dans cette année
cette année l'été inaugure est peu avant
l'assassinât du commissaire dé
dédaigneront donc oui il ya toujours un
retard mais c'était une descente retard
cette corporation est fantastique elle
est prête à travailler dans des locaux
qui t'es pas bon être avec des bagnoles
qui ne sont pas capables de rattraper un
voleur qui lunettes en moto ça c'était
encore acceptable par les policiers mais
ce qu'il ne l'est plus c'est qu'on les
mette en danger délibérément c'est à
dire qu'on soit dans la tentative
d'homicide volontaire comme on l'a vu
avec ses tirs aujourd'hui la justice ne
protège plus accorder protège plus était
une espionne lorsque par l'efficacité de
leur travail ils arrêtent des
délinquants il les voit ressortir pour
recommencer les mêmes choses et qu'ils
ont donc l'impression que leur mission
pour lequel il donne tout à savoir faire
une énergie le résultat dépend au bout
non pas de leur faute mais par
simplement l'organisent le système
pédales et le judiciaire alors le
gouvernement a annoncé plusieurs mesures
cette semaine et notamment le déblocage
d'une enveloppe de 250 millions d'euros
le gouvernement dit aussi qu'il va
réouvrir les discussions autour de la
légitime défense vous saluer ses
décisions je sais lui les 250 millions
mais qui viennent trotta attendait même
est ce que quelque part même si chef du
gouvernement a pris du retard explique
quand même charlie hebdo n'est pas un
élément qui aurait pu le déclencheur de
cette prise de conscience qu'il fallait
vraiment rattraper un retard s'il
existait et donner tous les équipements
il fallait est effectivement éviter aux
policiers de faire des tâches inutiles
de type gardes statiques dans des
hôpitaux et cetera et cetera faire le
planton est-ce qu'on ne pouvait pas
prendre conscience de cela plus tôt
aujourd'hui 250 millions c'est encore un
cadeau est-ce que c'est noël encore où
est ce que ce sera tenue parce qu'il n'y
a plus que six mois je crois qu'il faut
effectivement que ce soit dur mais je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le symbole c'est
effectivement les faire que la prise en
charge judiciaire et pénale de ceux des
policiers arrêtent soit effective et que
d'autre part effectivement on transforme
à l'égal de skier pour la gendarmerie le
droit de légitime défense même si il est
reconnu que dans le cas de
viry-châtillon les policiers agressés ou
l'entourage aurait pu faire des tas de
lausanne mais je crois qu'il faut que
les policiers municipaux soient capables
de réagir le mieux possible vis-à-vis
date ans d'attentats à leur vie on peut
vous le vous l'avez évoqué aussi les
missions un duo policiers nationaux il y
en a peut-être trop aujourd'hui est ce
que le but c'est aussi est ce qu une
bonne idée serait de renforcer le rôle
de la police municipale dans certaines
missions oui bien sûr c'est
complémentaire il faudra la bonne heure
je ne vais pas
dire que la police municipale n'a pas à
être formés là certainement être formé
des tâches dont elle n'avait pas la
responsabilité c'est que si on fait
évoluer son statut et ses
responsabilités faut la forme et parce
que c'est pas ça ne s'improvise pas donc
ça je suis d'accord là dessus il faut
aussi que quelque part on se spécialise
peut-être les politiques on est une
vraie chaîne de valeur autour finalement
la lutte contre le terrorisme sa demande
à savoir faire qui va de travail
depuis le juge jusqu'aux jusqu'aux
policiers c'est une chaîne de valeurs de
compétence qu'il fallait remettre en
place pour traiter fication des choses
en attendant oui la police municipale
doit avoir un rôle renforcé mais avec
les formations au possible qu'ils sont
nécessaires justement à saint quentin en
yvelines il ya la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux qui va renforcer
les équipements de ses policiers
municipaux
la maire de la ville annonce il ya
quelques jours l'arrivée prochaine de
pistolets à impulsion électrique
aussi appelée taser reportage
objectif assurer leur sécurité les cinq
agents et bientôt six de la police
municipale de voisins-le-bretonneux vont
recevoir d'ici quelques mois une
formation pour usage de pistolets à
impulsion électrique
un équipement en plus pour répondre
également aux nouvelles menaces depuis
les attentats par exemple je demande à
mes policiers de faire des fouilles aux
entrées aux entrées des établissements
publics lorsqu'il ya une manifestation
aujourd'hui quelque part ils sont assez
démunis s'il devait être attaqués dans
ce contexte là par exemple comme il
porte l'uniforme c'est vrai que ce sont
des cibles potentielles dont
l'opposition municipale les avis
divergent quant à l'armement des agents
si à gauche jean h estime que la
démarche va trop loin à droite en
revanche les taser sont jugés
insuffisants un nouveau débat que refuse
alexandra rosetti ce qui me gêne
beaucoup dans les raisonnements
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a le sentiment
qu'on attend beaucoup plus deux
démissions qui ne sont pas les leurs
pour lesquelles ils ne sont pas formés
on a une police nationale pour ça on a
des unités spéciales et je pense qu'il
ya une grosse confusion en ce moment
c'était une confusion des genres
l'arrivée des pistolets à impulsion
électrique ne devrait pas être
officielle avant fin 2010 est l
installation de 15 nouvelles caméras de
vidéo surveillance est également prévue
jean marie thé tard c'est une question
qui revient de plus en plus dans le
débat faut-il armer les policiers
municipaux la ville d'elancourt par
exemple va le faire c'est pas le cas le
voisin à monsieur c'est pas une arme
létale le taser mais est-ce qu'il faut
armer les police municipaux vous êtes
pour vous je dis oui tout dépend de la
taille de la commune tout dépend aussi
de la période de formation tout dépend
des effectifs de police on va dire oui
n'importe quel rôle que ce soit une
adhésion entre les services politique de
la mairie et des services de police il
faut qu'on prenne le temps où qu'on
définisse toutes les conditions je crois
que ça se reproduise pas et que si des
communes ne veulent pas le faire qu'elle
ne fasse pas politique à présent avec
les déplacements des candidats à la
primaire qui se multiplient dans les
yvelines en début de semaine bruno le
maire était à saint germain en laye le
candidat du renouveau comme ils aiment
s'appeler a développé quelques grandes
lignes de son programme reportage sur
des images divines une première
nous allons arriver au sommet quelles
que soient les difficultés parce que les
français veulent le renouvellement de la
vie politique de faire preuve de
renouveau bruno le maire veut garder le
cap et répète son message à l'envi
depuis des semaines un slogan est une
marque de fabrique également scandé hier
par l'ancien ministre de l'agriculture
en meeting à saint germain en laye et
qui semble ravir ses futurs électeurs à
la primaire
c'est déjà ce qui me pousse à aller vers
bruno le maire puisque j'exclus voter
pour quelqu'un qui a pas un casier
judiciaire vierge
j'exclus de voter pour les sortants
puisqu'ils ont un bilan le fait de
porter une certaine éthique pour moi
c'est très important
un certain dynamisme
une jeunesse
et l'envi de nouveaux éducation sécurité
ou encore économie le candidat à la
primaire a développé une partie de son
programme devant plusieurs dizaines de
ses partisans lui qui reste optimiste
malgré des sondages qui le placent loin
derrière encore les ténors du parti
beaucoup de gens me disent voilà on va
très bien pour vous mais on veut avoir
l'assurance que nicolas sarkozy soit
battu donc on va voter pour alain juppé
je connaissais pas une bonne motivation
pour son vote on doit voter pour un
projet et pour une personne qui porte ce
projet pas contre un homme ou contre une
personne ce deuxième déplacement dans
les yvelines en l'espace de quelques
mois a permis également au député de
l'eure de mesurer ses soutiens dans le
département on a aujourd'hui environ
1200 militants sur le département ce qui
fait une force de mobilisation
importante et on a aujourd'hui à peu
près 120 130 élus locaux qui nous ont
rejoint un certain nombre de maires
laurent bros philippe benassaya bernard
grouchko plusieurs conseillers
départementaux et régionaux et donc on a
une vraie force politique et populaire
qui permet de porter notre candidat
prochain grand oral pour bruno le maire
jeudi 3 novembre date du deuxième débat
de la primaire
vous jean marie thé tard vous êtes un
soutien fervent de jean françois copé
dans cette campagne des primaires c'est
plutôt rare dans le département des
yvelines pourquoi vous souhaitez jean
françois copé je crois que j'ai adhéré
jeu lorsque c'était le moment à toutes
les idées de jean françois copé sur la
nécessité de réformer une droite
décomplexée il y avait dans l'énoncé de
cette droite décomplexée à sa tombe de
vérité qui paraissait audacieuse nous
déplacer à l'époque et qui aujourd'hui
sont chose courante dans dans les
paroles de tous les candidats à cette
présidence et à quelle vérité sur
l'immigration ce qu'ils disent sur la
sécurité scolaire à jos et sur le
caractère sur le caractère régalien sur
le fait que la droite ne doit pas avoir
de complexes de dire qu'effectivement il
ya salon de difficultés de 10 de mettre
des mots sur les maux bref il avait il
énoncé un certain nombre de vérités qui
tu es dont on se gaussait dont on disait
que ce n'était pas convenable en fait
depuis
tout ça est devenu très convenable mais
moi je préfère effectivement soutenir
abandonner ceux qui ont eu le courage un
moment donné de lancer ses idées
soutenir jean françois copé même s'il
est crédité encore malgré un bon premier
débat de l'avis des spécialistes
toujours crédité de 1 ou 2 %
d'intentions de vote je n'ose pas qui va
gagner concrètement la primaire âge je
l'aï dit je suis débuté j'aime ma
fonction de débuter et je ne me prononce
pas pour la primaire ou pour un soutien
en fonction d'une promesse pour d'être
ministre demain ou d'avoir je ne sais
quel rôle moi ce qui m'intéresse est
d'adhérer à des idées de soutenir
l'évolution de ses idées et si jean
françois copé ne gagne pas la primaire
il jouera de toute manière un rôle par
rapport à son socle de valeurs et ce
qu'il dit maintenant seront ne recule
plus et moi je souhaite je veux que
effectivement cette formule on ne recule
plus sûres puisse perdurer et devenir
une des valeurs du prochain président
quel qu'il soit sa lettre justement la
question est-ce que vous conseille que
le soir du 27 novembre toute votre
famille politique sera se rangent il
saura se ranger derrière le candidat de
la primaire malgré les les guerres un
parfois très importante qui ait eu entre
par exemple nicolas sarkozy jean
françois copé fillon sarkozy fillon copé
juppé sarkozy c'est quand même un ton
assez durs dans cette primaire vous
pensez que le 27 novembre tout ça sera
oublié nous avons la chance d'avoir un
plateau de sept candidats à la primaire
qui sont toutes d'excellentes valeurs
qui sont des pions des stature d'homme
d'état ou de femme d'état et qui savent
prendre leurs responsabilités le moment
venu le soir du 28 ils seront prendre
leurs responsabilités cette derrière le
vainqueur après je me méfie un peu plus
des écuries ou des dés des ultras jeudi
est un peu comme au foot les champions
s'ils sont les ultras les écuries les
écuries ce sont ceux qui sont les plus
près de l'équipe qui se voit d'avenir
aider les ultras sur quelques fois les
militants de base qui sont tellement
déçu de tout le temps qu'ils mettent à à
soutenir un candidat je crois
qu'effectivement le rôle des des
candides et candidat à la primaire le
soir de la première sera d'assumer leurs
responsabilités je sais qu'ils le feront
et de dire à leurs troupes on vend sans
une dernière question oui ou non jean
marie têtards est ce que vous serez vous
souhaitez de candidats de nouveau à
l'élection législative le sort est
scellé constitue offre oui ou non
oui tweet d'une part d'autre part si
j'ai reçu l'investiture en plus du
comité national de mon parti et je pense
que les candidats qui seront élues le
soir du 28
28 novembre ne remettront pas en cause
du gros metro à la marge en cause
certaines candidatures c'est la fin de
ce set 8 hebdo merci et jean-marie tête
avant nous avoir accompagnés dans cette
demi heure je rappelle que vous êtes
député de la 9e circonscription des
yvelines et maire de houdan merci à vous
aussi de nous avoir suivis bon hockey à
tous et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]